[Music]
your Tick Tock apartment tour was iconic
we do have a little small mouse problem
they um at night while we're sleeping
come out and clean up the crumbs that my
son drops on the floor I feel like a lot
of people outed themselves for having
never been to New York when the Outreach
brought the mouse how because it's like
um uh everybody has mice
that you need to oh regularly
distinction
absolutely every building in New York
has mine like when I was little I used
to have so much fun catching them and
releasing them okay now you're taking it
yeah but now it's like I'm tired you
know do I want to go catch a mouse after
a 16-hour day I know I'm just gonna
think convince myself that the mouse is
a pet that apartment tour the just can't
look away Fashions the very famous X
Julia Fox is super Unapologetic and we
hear her take on all the things in her
podcast forbidden fruits with Coco's
Nikki to cash season two premieres today
on Spotify I think it was in the first
episode Julie you said that being Stone
kind of helps with parentino at all it
does I hear a lot of parents say that
wine used to be the I I was gonna say
but like you know Millennial moms are
kind of we're we move we're moving away
from alcohol okay so I'm gonna run
through some hot topics I'm I want to
know if you guys are going to cover on
the pot or not celebs on weight loss
injections I actually haven't talked
about it but all these people are coming
for me saying that I take the weight
loss things yeah I'm not and I've never
are we gonna be talking about Julia's
date with Drake No
are we gonna talk about your friendship
with Madonna
oh she oh she's my dream girl yeah we'll
get there we'll get there we're
manifesting yeah on the pods you've had
Billy McFarlane I mean pass guess
includes include Anna Del V what is the
prerequisite to be a guest on forbidden
fruits you have to be a forbidden person
we just have to be obsessed with you in
some way you know what I mean it doesn't
necessarily have to be that like you're
dark yeah or that you've been canceled
or that you're about we would love that
you know what has been the hardest part
for you Julie of adjusting to this like
Fame I mean my interpersonal like my
interpersonal relationship with my
personal life
is the same so like I don't ever like I
forget that I'm famous it's not
something that like it I I can't explain
it but I'm literally still doing the
same things same people same places same
everything so I'm
kind of I guess living in a bubble and
disassociated from everything also you
have friends like Nikki and also your
son Valentino I'm sure to help keep you
grounded oh of course yeah yeah yeah I'm
super blessed with the people in my life
I love it Nikki said yeah keep her in
check
she does Nikki tells the truth she's
honest so if Julia were to date again
which I'm sure is gonna happen what type
of man would you want for her or person
somebody rich
okay
life is hard yeah well just you know
somebody that has a job and you know
insecure yes because you know she has a
child and
comfortably really busy so I don't have
to see them that's the next thing I was
gonna say travels a lot not home all the
time
okay so she crossed off all that I mean
that's the checklist right there Julia
obviously you are a style Muse okay I
brought some of your more iconic looks
and I want both of your reactions too
okay so
the body bag oh my God the body bag the
thoughts questions concerned that's me
um in the beginning trying to get Nikki
to do the podcast really oh yeah that's
me and Nikki just dragging her yelling
come on be good at this Nikki is this
you it's actually me yeah I think people
thought it was Kim but it's me
okay I mean this is Iconic also because
you're walking in the show with the
horns yeah I mean did you want to keep
this I did it feels very you yeah I love
it oh Valentino at the Milan Fashion
Week I was just looking at this last
night he was such a good boy how do you
decide what to wear for this show
um I mean it was pretty easy because if
you want I don't know if you ever go
into like a diesel store but it's like
everything is amazing yeah it's like a
kid in a candy store for me the
horsetail oh yeah what is it giving
um
and finally come on you're a fashiony
poodle oh I love the poodles I also love
the poodle yeah I feel like it's very
you it is very me it's not very truly
but that's why I like that she wore it I
like seeing her and her colors yeah yeah
and she feels out of the darkness the
pink the pink not you I don't really
have you seen her in pink yeah and I've
never really yeah how can you step
outside of the box I'm working on my
relationship with pink but I love pink
like I love when my friends wear pink if
I'm dressing my friends I always put
them like you look great I'm always feel
uncomfortable in it for some reason
really I don't know I have to I have to
like look into that what it is with me
and my femininity at the time yeah
there's uh something we gotta connect
we'll get into it this season Julia and
Nikki are on camera for the podcast and
they gave me a studio tour of course we
had to start in wardrobe oh we love
feathers we love colors we have to point
out this like share Horowitz moment I
know come on as if I'm obsessed
red hair oh it goes around red hair
chokers amazing
don't you think we play dress up and
then Julia even gave me her famous boxer
I wanna know what's the secret to your
signature Fox eyeliner look I mean the
secret is to just go big okay if you
think it's too much go even more you
know let's go big baby let's do it let's
do it okay so
we're gonna just start here
and like it doesn't have to be perfect
you can always go in and
fix it and make it sharp and whatnot and
you do this every day
not every day but liquid eyeliner is the
way to go with this for this type of
graphic eye but then you know sometimes
if you want a more smudgy look something
a little less defined I would go but we
want to find right we do we want
definition so let me ask you Julia what
do your pillow cases look like oh yeah
let's just say I can't have guests right
we missed you at the Vanity Fair party
this year I know I know what's it like
kind of rubbing elbows with all those
people
you know what it feels like honestly you
know that scene in the Titanic where
Leonardo DiCaprio like
um goes to dinner with all the rich
people and he's like yes I'm here with
you buying folks and he's like literally
just he's leaning in but he's like I do
not belong here yeah yeah it feels like
that
yeah I just recently rewatched that
movie and
movie you're like that's me at the
Vanity Fair yeah okay so I didn't I did
them different I did this one more like
thinner and longer and this one shorter
and for a reason no it just came out
that way yeah and I apologize but she
apologizes what do you guys think I
think I look pretty Fierce wait before
we go I wanted to ask you about your
bleached eyebrows which you don't have
now I don't have
and I have to cosplay as a normie so I
need a eyebrows yeah I need my eyebrows
back you said the bleach brows were man
repellent they are does that mean you
might be ready for a man now that
they're going back girl could only drink
she's like no I got a career first it's
true and a baby a full-time and that too
exactly it's a huge well I feel like
you're a child now that I have this
makeover so thank you thank you guys
thank you E.T
[Music]